Lauren handy herb Garrity Heather edoni
William Goodman and John Hinshaw
remember those names
those are the five latest political
prisoners to be thrown in jail by evil
regime apparatchics right here in our
own country and I don't throw the word
evil around lightly
here the word is entirely appropriate
because the evil apparatchics in
Washington DC are imprisoning these five
Patriots for the simple Act of
demonstrating against abortion these
five pro-life Advocates demonstrated in
defense of babies at an abortion Mill an
infanticide Factory and for that they
face over a decade in prison
they didn't set off any bombs they
didn't shoot anybody they didn't do any
of that they just demonstrated against
infanticide their demonstration
apparently violates the face act a
clinton-era rule
outlawing any interference with
infanticide whatsoever
BLM can block highways
environmentalists antifa they can shut
down any City they like they can stop
mothers from driving their children to
the hospital actually as we saw in one
particularly high profile incident
recently and it doesn't matter they
don't even get a slap on the wrist
but no one is allowed to so much as
stand between an abortionist and his
next victim
so these pro-lifers have already been
sent to jail potentially for months as
they await sentencing
even more egregious the demonstration
that got these pro-life Advocates
imprisoned was a direct response to the
earlier discovery of illegal abortions
performed by the baby butcher cesare
santangelo all abortions are crimes in
the sense that they violate the natural
law but santangelo's abortions were also
crimes according to the civil law and
they were uncovered only because
pro-lifers stumbled upon the remains of
full-term babies being thrown out with
medical waste a story that our legal and
media establishment quickly swept under
the rug and now to tie up Loose Ends
they're sweeping the pro-life activists
under the rug and straight into prison
too all of which makes one Wonder
just like Mitchell and Webb
are we the Baddies
we talk a lot about despotic regimes
around the world one of the key markers
of those regimes
is forget about the people they're
killing the Injustice against the most
vulnerable people in their Nations
one of the key markers is how many
political prisoners they lock up and
over the course of the last few years
we've gone from relatively few
to quite a lot
hundreds of January 6th there is having
the book thrown at them over trivial
transgressions in most cases
oh they're just rioters some said then
okay and then the government arrested
the former president
and current leader of the opposition oh
well it's just Trump he did it to
himself some people said then the
government arrested the opposition
leaders lawyers and staff oh well
some said some people realize that was a
little bit too far but some people they
said oh well serves them right
they were working for Trump
well now
the government is rounding up ordinary
Americans who voice their opposition to
the wholesale Slaughter of infants
now those people are facing over a
decade in prison for disagreeing with
perhaps the clearest form of Injustice
in our entire country
that's a lot of dissidents getting
thrown in the clink in a short period of
time
and there's still a lot of time to go
before the election that the Liberals
refuse to lose I'm Michael Knowles this
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers very
fitting because I had good ranchers last
night it was a delicious juicy double
cheeseburger best burgers I've ever had
I guess though I could do this ad most
days of the week and I probably would
have also had good ranchers the night
before then too get great meat at a
secure price 30 bucks off your order
with my code Knowles goodranchors.com
use code Knowles today speaking of our
sacred democracy and elections uh
Ukraine President Vladimir zielinski the
great defender of democracy has said
that he's not going to hold any
elections anymore and he's only going to
hold them if the West pays for it so if
we pay for his elections maybe he'll do
it otherwise he's too busy defending
democracy so he can't he can't hold his
own elections now
here in the United States
the activists The Advocates who are
willing to put their freedom on the line
they give me a lot of Hope young people
in particular give me a lot of Hope and
one young person especially
is giving me a lot of Hope
I I saw this kid's clip go viral because
a number of people tagged me in his clip
because I guess some people thought this
young man wearing smart looking chinos
and a nice button-down Oxford shirt has
his hair parted a little bit off on the
side
they thought maybe this young man and I
bear a passing resemblance this is a 12
year old boy
from Harrison School District Two
in southeast Colorado Springs who was
kicked out of class for having a Gadsden
flag on his backpack in a Gadsden flag
that's the one with the snake and it
says don't tread on me this is one of
the very earliest American flags it
dates back to the American Revolution it
was a flag that was waived very high by
the Patriots During the Revolution and
the Dei you know
counselor and enforcer of liberal
policies at this school
haranged this young man and his mother
for having the audacity to show a symbol
of the American Revolution the reason
we do not want to play this way is due
to its origins
of slavery and slave trade that is what
was
um just put a pause right there so you
see the mother says in the American
Revolution and the woman at the same
time she goes in slavery it's about now
of course the Gadsden flag
has nothing whatsoever to do with
slavery it's just com this isn't
something that is debatable or well you
have your opinion eye of my opinion
there's it it just has no connection I
don't know how else to put it if you're
in any way literate about history of not
that long ago just do a couple hundred
years you would know that but why does
this counselor lady think that the
Gadsden flag has something to do with
slavery well because she knows that the
mother is right
that the flag has to do with the
American Revolution and presumably she's
read
the only popular document that has
suggested that the American Revolution
was about slavery and that was Nicole
Hannah Jones's the New York Times 1619
project the thesis of which was the
American Revolution was fought to
protect slavery it's completely made up
even left-wing academic historians wrote
a letter saying this is complete
nonsense it's not true whatsoever the
New York Times did after the fact very
sutley have to retract that claim but it
doesn't matter they put millions and
millions of dollars into spreading this
total lie this fake news and it's made
it into schools it didn't just sit in
the newspaper the point of it was to
affect curricula and it has affected
curricula including the many many very
ignorant
I don't say that to disparage these
people I'm just pointing out they don't
know a lot of things a very ignorant
apparatchics who are working around
these schools who I don't know they read
it once in the New York Times and okay
so now that's the established fact so
you can see how an ignorant person could
be duped by that well the consequences
if those ignorant people are in
positions of power then they're going to
boot out a basic American symbol keep
going
[Music]
the
don't tread on me
because we can't have that in and around
other kids so that's what I was trying
and then he said you were close so I was
like oh well yeah it has nothing to do
with slavery that's like the
Revolutionary War patch that was
displayed when they were fighting the
British I am here to enforce the policy
that was provided by the district
and definitely you have every right to
not agree with it I mean
says that he's allowed to wear that if
you like go on their website
I love this it goes on and on for I
think two and a half three minutes
and that woman which she said this is
the most depressing part of the whole
video it's what this ignorant bureaucrat
at this school says
yes about slavery the mother goes it's
just not she goes yeah okay well I
obviously don't have any arguments to
back up my points so
um look
I'm just following orders man
I'm just here to enforce the policy of
the district I don't know anything about
the the reasoning for the policy I don't
know anything about American history I
don't care about the Justice of the
policy or the truth of the claim that
it's based on
I'm just kicking your kid out of class
anyway
I don't care I don't care
one of the oldest Flags
in American history it's it's not even
my favorite flag the the Gadsden flag is
in many ways more Anodyne than the
earlier American flags the Gadsden flag
is today often associated with the
Libertarians
or the tea party it's often associated
with people who basically just are
focused on economic issues or who just
want to be left alone
it's it's not the flag waved by hardcore
social conservatives usually it's not
the flag waved by the populists today
usually then you could see them maybe it
would be slightly more controversial
it's not it's way by nice ordinary
Libertarians it's it's waived by
sophomores in college who read Ein Rand
for the first time it's waived by people
who have passing interest in 18th
century American history it's so basic
it's so anodyne
there are there are much more hardcore
early American flags the very first
American flag the oldest known flag
there's a flag called the Bedford flag
and the Bedford flag is a as an arm
covered in a knight's coat of arms
holding a sword and it says vinche out
Mariah win conquer or die
that's a little bit more hardcore
and uh I think actually those two flags
represent a shift in the way the right
is thinking about politics for many
years for probably the last 30 years
especially over the last 15. the
American right has been the Gadsden flag
right don't tread on me leave me alone
do whatever you want to do just don't
make me pay for it and go do your own
thing and I'm gonna do my own thing that
hasn't worked because bureaucrats like
that lady in that school are always
going to come and try to stop you from
doing what you want to do and worse yet
stop you from exercising your rights and
worse yet stop you from speaking the
truth that's always going to happen we
live in a society no man is an island
entire unto himself so I think you're
going to see a shift from that early
American flag the Gadsden flag
toward an even earlier one vinche out
Mariah we are going to win these
cultural battles we're gonna Duke them
out we're gonna win these cultural
battles or our view is just going to die
out and our Traditions are going to die
out and our way of life is going to die
out but we are not all going to just
Kumbaya agree to disagree and go along
to get along we are going to have to
enshrine certain things is true and
certain things is false either true
American history is going to be taught
in schools or the 1619 project BS is
going to be taught in schools either
that lady is going to be enforcing a
false view of American history and bad
education policies or we're going to
boot her out of that school and we're
going to get a good educator in there to
enforce good policies with true facts
this is this is what Ron DeSantis saw in
Florida
this is why DeSantis Focus so much on
education we all have to do it and now
just before just to put a bow on it
I know people have asked if this young
man and I have any relation
I would just like to say
that boy is not my son to the best of my
knowledge as
we hear in the Odyssey by Homer as we
hear in William Shakespeare it is a wise
child who knows his own father but
as far as I can tell that boy is not my
son I'm proud of him anyway I'm very
proud that's a very
sharply dressed rightly ordered
well-behaved courageous young man good
on him and good on the mother
when our society is collapsing
you're going to want some tangible
assets you're going to want to check out
Birch gold right now text Knowles to 98
98.98 as central banks and countries
like China China India and Australia
begin transitioning to a digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
a digital currency the government could
track every single purchase you make
officials could even prohibit you from
purchasing certain products and easily
freeze or Seize Your Money these are
some of the reasons that concerned
Americans reach out to Birch gold they
want to have a physical asset like gold
that is independent of the US dollar you
can protect your IRA or 401K by
diversifying with gold from Birch gold
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now learn if gold is right for you
too text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 and
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with a Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diverse into gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
upon text Knowles Canada wies to 98 98
where did this crazy educator get this
idea that the American Revolution is
about slavery
she got it from one lady Nicole Hannah
Jones Nicole Hannah Jones is a favorite
huckster of the left she is a fabulous
from The New York Times who passes
herself off as some kind of academic
though she's not known for any actual
academic work she just goes on to
liberal media outlets and whines about
racism and makes up stories about
history and wins prizes for it so Nicole
Hannah Jones just did the same thing she
showed up on CNN with Jake Tapper to
explain
the very rapid spread you probably
didn't even notice it of white supremacy
since 1968 it is no longer legal in this
country to explicitly discriminate
against black Americans so of course
we've learned over the last
um 60 years that you have to use
different language that you have to use
language that appears to be race neutral
but that sends the same dog whistle so
we can look at you know Ron DeSantis
running on this uh platform of against
what he's calling vocalism but where
those of us who study history who
understand
um uh the society that we live in
understand that that's often coded as
language against black Americans as
language against other marginalized
groups and how do we know that well he
also banned the teaching of
African-American advanced placement
studies in the state so yes we we do see
a more coded language but it's also a
language of
um you know that's not often that coded
I mean Donald Trump
is you know came to office on a pretty
openly white nationalist campaign
um we see people like Tucker Carlson who
are allowed to have a major platform on
the most watched um Cable News
television in the country they're all
white supremacists it's all it's all
white nationalism okay okay
if Donald Trump
and Tucker Carlson and Ron DeSantis
if the three most prominent
conservatives in America
doing different things in different
places at different levels of government
and Society if if it just so happens
that the three most prominent
conservatives in America are white
nationalists then I guess we're all just
white nationalists aren't we again I
found out Larry Elder you know larielle
I know he's black but he's a white
nationalist because that's what the L.A
time said
Candace Owens she's a white nationalist
obviously we were told that uh someone
in the chat our friend Arun a member of
the crime de La Creme here he pointed
out yesterday in the chat that Vivek
ramaswamy he called him he said he's not
the black face of white supremacy he's
the Red Dot on the brown forehead of
white supremacy everybody's a white
supremacist
if if they disagree with Nicole Hannah
Jones to which I say okay
I guess that's what we are now I thought
the phrase had more of a meaning than
that I guess it doesn't so okay whatever
no did but did you hear
did you hear conservatives we called you
white supremacists all right I guess
whatever whatever man like okay
aren't you upset aren't you gonna defend
yourself against that charge
no no I'm not because I don't you've
demonstrated that one the phrase doesn't
mean anything and two that you're you're
not arguing in good faith so no why
would I defend myself against that
did Socrates defend himself at his trial
did our Lord defend himself
during the passion during his trial
no why why is that
because of their particular virtue in
you know in the case of Our Lord is
perfect virtue uh yeah that's part of it
also just as a very practical Prudential
matter what good is to be done with
you're never going to convince somebody
like Nicole Hannah Jones that you're not
a white supremacist she thinks if you're
white you're a white supremacist and if
you're a black person who disagrees with
her you're a white supremacist so who
cares who cares just let it roll on this
is another big shift in the American
right
I think even 10 years ago the American
right was very eager to prove to the
supposedly open-minded good faith
Centrist liberals that were not racist
no actually the Democrats are the real
racists and we're not the re but I I
something has shifted at least in my
mind over the last few years which is I
I've come to realize that the phrases
it's never used in good faith even this
term white nationalism virtually no one
had ever even heard of that term until a
few years ago when the libs used it
because the word racism had lost its
power because the phrase white supremacy
had lost its power because it had been
so abused so okay now that's the new one
whatever you're gonna call me that I
take that to be a badge of honor I
remember Ann Coulter made this point she
visited us when I was in college
she gave a talk and she said kids don't
don't be discouraged when a liberal
calls you a racist you know you've won
the argument so true and I have I've won
some kind of Lottery because several
nights a week I have the opportunity
to eat delicious steak from good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
I don't know about you but this summer
heat in Nashville feels hotter than a
two dollar pistol and thanks to
inflation everyone's feeling the heat in
more ways than one one thing that you
will not sweat this summer and this fall
and this winter
is the price of your meat thanks to good
ranchers my price is locked in for two
years yours can be too price lock
guarantee on me yes it's amazing I don't
get how their finances work to to allow
this to happen but it's incredible and
the the meat quality is also incredible
when I was a wee lad steak was a very
rare special occasion kind of thing and
now good ranchers will bring you
extraordinarily high quality steak at an
extremely reasonable price to your door
to say nothing of all the other great
food they've got the chicken and the
pork and the burgers which I had last
night which are the best I've ever had
go to goodranchors.com use code Knowles
kwles for 30 bucks off any box there's
promo code Knowles kwles
goodranchers.com goodranchors.com
American Meat delivered when wokeness is
permeating
every aspect of your life it's hard to
know where to turn to for guidance
I've got some good news
our friend Dennis Prager has all of the
answers in his daily wire plus series
prageru Masters program
in master's program Dennis Prager has
gathered 40 years worth of wisdom and is
sharing it on a number of wide-ranging
subjects Dennis offers useful advice on
marriage happiness how to be a good
person plus so much more he even dares
to explain the differences between men
and women in a world that wants to make
you woke Dennis wants to make you wise
all episodes are now available only for
daily wire Plus members so do not wait
go to dailywireplus.com to become a
member and watch prageru master's
program today
speaking of
white presidential candidates a little
bit of a rough transition uh Chris
Christie is lobbying more attacks at
Donald Trump and this attack actually
ties into our whole broad theme of the
day this attack is that Donald Trump
wants to be an authoritarian leader
I think what we have is a Donald Trump
problem and that right now what's gone
on is that people view Donald Trump
synonymously with the Republican party
and that if you oppose Trump that's
somehow favoring Biden and many
Republicans don't want to do that for
very obvious reasons
um and I think that that's why we need
to have this full debate and discussion
that we just really started on Wednesday
night about who should be leading our
party and who should be leading our
country and I've said very clearly on
the authoritarian side of things this is
Donald Trump's problem not the
Republican party's problem he's the guy
who thinks that uh Vladimir Putin's an
excellent leader and Brilliant he's the
guy who thinks that President XI is
straight out of Hollywood he's the guy
who thinks Kim Jong-un
um is wonderful I mean these are things
that he has said about these
authoritarian leaders and it's because
Donald Trump would like to be one
himself he wants to be an authoritarian
so
Christy bases his cheap shot on cheaper
shots which is Donald Trump has pointed
out that Xi Jinping is a apparently a
pretty competent leader of his country
which is just indisputably true
he's able to hold and exercise power
pretty effectively in China in a very
large country that's impressive
he's able to
build up his nation's economy and
maintain social order that's impressive
I'm not saying he's a good guy not
saying I agree with him that's not what
Donald Trump is saying either
same thing about Putin you think about
after communism after the collapse of
the Russian form of government you had
this failed guy Boris Yeltsin who had
all sorts of personal problems who
wasn't able to maintain her wield power
opened up his country to a lot of
corruption and then Vladimir Putin comes
in he has been able to maintain power
pretty effectively and he's remained
very popular among the Russian people so
you're not saying he's a good guy if you
if you point out that this is an
effective leader which is obviously what
Trump was doing here but Christine needs
those cheap shots those disingenuous
attacks to build up his broader point
which is that Donald Trump
he loves authoritarian he's an
authoritarian the conservatives are not
but he is
okay
Donald Trump waived an LGBT flag on the
campaign Trail in 2016. okay Donald
Trump is in no way an authoritarian
leader unless we're defining
authoritarian leader as
liberal from seven years ago
overstating this too much Donald Trump
speaks and acts in a rather liberal Way
by historical standards because he's
slightly more traditional and
conservative than I don't know Barack
Obama or something like that now
according to the squishes and the
Liberals he's an authoritarian he's the
second coming of Francisco Franco but
it's completely ridiculous but let's go
with Christy for a second let's say
Christy we're right let's say Donald
Trump really were an authoritarian let's
say that having men go into the men's
bathroom constitutes authoritarianism
for instance
what's the alternative to that
the alternative to supposed conservative
authoritarianism is liberal
totalitarianism but make no mistake
liberalism is totalitarian
and what's the distinction between the
two authoritarianism is when the
government says hey don't do stuff in
the streets that's crazy and weird don't
don't don't just follow whatever impulse
you've got in your appetites and parade
around on the street wearing leather
costumes smacking each other around
maybe don't do that okay
that's like that's what we're calling
authoritarian these days but like for
instance the Liberals called Victor
Orban in Hungary authoritarians
completely ridiculous but even if he
were what are they saying as
authoritarian is he goes out and he says
hey we're a Christian country you can
believe however you want to believe you
can engage in basically whatever
practices you want to engage in
in the privacy of your own home but in
public we're going to be a Christian
country and have Christian morality
that's all he said that's that's what
they call authoritarian
but what the Liberals insist on
is not only that you have to do what
they want you to do in public
you have to do it in private too you're
not allowed
to
be a conservative within the privacy of
your own home you're not allowed to
encourage conservative rituals within
the privacy of your own home they're
going to shut down your churches
they're going to go they're going to go
send the FBI in to spy on your mass
they're going to send the FBI to go
knock on your door if you're a father of
seven but you're a pro-life Advocate and
you're a little too vocal they're going
to show up to your house
they're not they're going to if you
oppose the LGBT flag oh they're
that's going to be a problem you're not
going to get to wear a Gadsden flag
you're not going to get to maintain your
Traditions that's called totalitarianism
you're the the
authoritarianism as people talk about it
today in a very shallow way it's just
that there's a Bedrock set of rules that
people have to broadly respect in public
and then they can do whatever they want
totalitarianism is when the media when
the education system when the scientific
establishment when obviously the
bureaucracy and the institutions of the
government when all of that has to
uphold a very rigid ideological set of
views and if anyone breaks them it's
where members of the community it's
where members of the family are going to
be encouraged to rat on each other to
attack each other where you're going to
be sent into Thanksgiving dinner not to
have a nice holiday with your family but
to go lecture to go scold your
conservative Uncle for his backward
views on
global warming or whatever that's
totalitarianism and if those are the two
options
conservatives so so-called
authoritarianism
where we say hey clean up the streets
and act normal versus liberal
totalitarianism GO RAD on your uncle and
call up the feds if he seems a little
too conservative
give me the conservative version baby
that's fine by me
I think the Chris is uh very steadily
collapsing and you know the biggest
irony of all here's the biggest irony of
it all
Chris Christie has made a big point in
the last couple of weeks of saying that
the most important thing we can do is
we've got to support Ukraine he's flown
to Kiev he's met with zelinski's he's
talked about the importance of just
continuing to spend money and arms and
Ratchet up this proxy war that we're
fighting with Russia in Ukraine we've
got to do it democracy is on the line
meanwhile
Vladimir zielinski the president of
Ukraine has just come out and announced
that he's not going to have elections
the the basic element of a democracy
this guy's not going to do
unless he said he's willing to consider
holding elections if the United States
pays for it
zielinski said
I told Senator Graham okay I can't I
can't do a Ukrainian accent I can't even
really do a Russian
he says I told Senator Graham if the
United States and Europe give us
financial support I'm sorry I will not
hold elections on credit I will not take
money from weapons and give it to
elections either but if you give me this
financial support if the
parliamentarians realize that we need to
do this then let's quickly change the
legislation and most importantly let's
take risks together
but no
otherwise I'm not holding these
elections
now I get it I get why a nation at War
would not hold elections I get why
Vladimir zielinski has declared martial
law
I totally get it
right they're at War it's an existential
fight
and also it was never about democracy
can we please cut the crap about
democracy here in the United States when
we pretend that electing Donald Trump is
a threat to democracy the people getting
what they want is a threat to democracy
or in Ukraine
we have to defend democracy we got to
suspend elections indefinitely so we can
defend democracy it's not about
democracy
what people are fighting for in Ukraine
is liberalism
and so-called Western values that's
where we say our we have an interest in
Ukraine because Russia is trying to
expand their sphere of influence and
Russia's illiberal and anti-western and
we're Western and we're very liberal and
we want to expand our sphere of
influence we want to push the Russians
out that's openly what people are
talking about once you get past the
facade of the Democracy talk which
should be all well and good I'm all for
the West uh maintaining its position and
hegemony and Power
but what are Western values what do we
mean by Western values
do we mean
Christendom do we mean Justice do we
mean the the values that built our
civilization and allowed it to flourish
do we mean even truth justice in the
American way the Superman values no
Western values today means
abortion
Western values means
that's the part they're gonna have to
bleep that out of YouTube Western values
means all sorts of degeneracy that's
what it's associated with it's not
associated with building new churches
it's not associated with encouraging
marriage and encouraging family
formation and encouraging virtue in fact
all of those things are on the decline
in the West
so that's what it's about now and
given that fact
can you see how some American
conservatives might be a little bit
skeptical of that might think it's not
worth the blood and the treasure and
dragging on a war endlessly with no end
in sight
I can understand that can you see why
some people might think Chris Christie
who is wrong about almost everything
might also be wrong about this
my favorite comment yesterday is from
Jake Anderson 3468 who says
telling people that there were good
governments prior to John Locke is like
pulling teeth I know this was a problem
for a long time after World War II
the Liberals did a great job of
infiltrating the American right and
turning the right into a bunch of Libs
but I think that's kind of fading away
I think we're moving back to it to a
little bit more of a traditional
classical
older understanding of politics in
America I think I think we're moving
back to where that Bedford flag Vince
now that that arm of the night recognize
well who were the Knights the knights
were Christian Soldiers
they weren't fighting for John Locke and
some totally abstracted Enlightenment
value they weren't fighting for
America's merely an idea and diversity
is our strength and we need to be more
and more liberal ever more so and let
people do it no they
they fought for the the values and the
beliefs and the way of life that made
our civilization great now speaking of
less than Democratic leaders not just in
Ukraine back here at home
speaking of despotic governments
you know Joe Biden got caught using a
pseudonym
two pseudonyms actually well actually
more than two pseudonyms but there were
variations on two main themes this was
the latest stage of Joe Biden had no
idea what Hunter Biden was doing in his
business
and it turned out he had some idea how
do we know that because Joe Biden
previously said I never talked to Hunter
about my business then we found out
Hunter admitted yeah they did talk about
the business well I didn't I wasn't
involved in it at all then we found out
he actually was meeting with the
business partners he was on 20 plus
phone calls with the corrupt people that
they were getting money from he was
writing handwritten notes he was well
okay those were just pleasantries though
we were just talking about the weather
okay well now we found out
while Joe was vice president he was
conducting business
overseas setting up phone calls with the
president of Ukraine
conducting business with his son Hunter
using a pseudonym
and still all throughout all of this
what we have heard the big excuse has
been look Joe Biden just loves his son
he just really loves his son his son was
going through a rough patch
a real rough patch but his son he's an
addict
his son no doubt is an addict his son he
was kind of prodigal yeah you could say
that again his son and he just loves his
son and he's not going to lose his son
so he was just trying to stay in touch
with his son
okay well now the National Archives have
uncovered as many as
5400 records
containing the pseudonyms that Joe Biden
used while he was vice president
approximately 5138 emails 25 electronic
files 200 pages of potentially
responsive records in response to a foia
search requested by the Southeastern
Legal Foundation
5400 records man
Joe Biden must really love his son and
really want to express that love for his
son as secretly as possible
why would Joe Biden use a pseudonym as
vice president
because he wants to avoid foia requests
because there are laws that allow for
transparency in government in the United
States and Joe Biden was doing things
that he did not want to be transparent
and he was doing those things with his
son don't you think if he merely loved
his son and just wanted to give him a
pat on the back attaboy we're here for
you son I think he wouldn't be ashamed
of doing that in public I think he
probably is a politician probably like
to do that in public
but that's not what was going on
Joe Biden
was shaking down foreign leaders or
having his proxy Hunter Biden Shakedown
foreign leaders on the Family's behalf
so this excuse is gone he really just
loves his son that excuses out the
window
you're seeing a lot of drip drip drip
drip drip of the Biden corruption it
probably doesn't matter if if Biden is
the only choice the Liberals will still
vote for him and he might well win
if though
there is another choice if a Gavin
Newsom really seems like a plausible
presidential candidate then this drip
drip drip
would seem to not be coincidental okay
as we're now a little over a year
outside of the election
there is a non-zero chance that putting
Health aside Joe Biden is not the
nominee I think still overwhelmingly the
chances he will be the nominee
this really opens up a door because it
is clear as day this guy is crooked
it's not just that I want to attack Joe
Biden I think there are some
Democrat presidents who are not crooked
crooked you know Barack Obama did some
corrupt things but he was an ideologue I
think he actually believed in what he
was doing not so Joe Biden Joe Biden
doesn't believe in anything and he's
enriched himself and his family
tremendously and that's coming out now
so
if Biden's out who's going to take over
if the Republicans managed to win what
happens well we had the debate
this was supposed to be the big shake-up
in the campaign
and the polls are out and according to
morning consult
Trump's lead is unshaken
Trump is as strong today as the front
runner of the GOP
as he was before the debate I know there
are a lot of people who are not going to
want to hear that but I'm giving it to
you straight man
I don't sugarcoat it I'm not gonna do
that thing the Democrats did in 2016.
you remember it was like three months
after Trump was sworn in and they would
say here's the one weird trick that
Bernie can use to still win the
nomination no man it's over the race
that race was over okay and this race is
not over but what we were told was just
wait until DeSantis starts to make moves
to run for president then he's going to
jump in the polls didn't happen well
just wait until he declares then he's
going to jump in the polls didn't happen
well just wait until the debate
then he's going to jump in the polls
you're seeing maybe a little movement in
certain States but
generally speaking
nationally Donald Trump still has a 44
point lead over Ron DeSantis according
to morning consult Trump is the first
choice for 58 percent of Republican
primary voters that's a clear majority
this is in a field of what nine or ten
people
in the clear majority say we want Trump
14 for DeSantis and lower numbers for
everybody else
this is as I predicted and some people
have accused me of Shilling for Trump
because I predicted this I would have
predicted this even if I totally
detested Donald Trump
the reason I predicted this is
the only way that the the debate could
have really mattered is if Trump were
there because the only person who could
really move the needle As Trump because
Trump had the dominant lead in the party
and continues to have the dominant lead
so the only the only person who could
have done something positively or
negatively to really shake up the race
would have been Donald Trump he's just
got a clear majority of the voters
and he didn't show up so you might say
well a lot of people watch the debate
and not that many people watched the
Tucker Carlson interview with Trump
maybe they did maybe they didn't it's
hard to tell what the Twitter analytics
really mean doesn't matter Trump could
have gone back home and watched a rerun
of Home Improvement
he didn't need to do anything by not
doing anything he protected himself
the only way for Trump to go at that
debate by showing up was down
what was he going to do he was going to
go from 58 to 59
. he already had so much strength in the
in the polls that very likely especially
the fact that Trump is a little loose
with his language
almost certainly the only way he could
have gone was down so he skipped and
avoided that and as a result the polls
basically are where they are
and the other candidates are going to
continue to Duke it out on on the
on the number two race so
one of those people who's making moves
and is pretty bold
the fake ramaswamy you know I like the
guy he's a friend of mine of some years
and there's one thing that I don't like
about Vivek there's one thing and I
listen friends have spats and I'm
willing to
come out with this one I
hated the rapping you know at the Iowa
State Fair he was rapping he did a rap
of Eminem Who I really can't stand I
don't like his music at all and he did
it and I know it worked and I know that
people got a kick out of it and it's
probably an effective campaign tactic
but I just
it drove me crazy and it drove Eminem
crazy too so Eminem has just come out
and demanded that Vivek stopped rapping
his music now this happens every cycle
anytime any candidate gets attention
and a candidate plays any popular song
at his rallies or his campaign stops
then the artist who 99 out of 100 times
his big lib comes out and makes a Big
Splash in the headlines you need to stop
using my song You're illegally playing
my song and I demand that you don't play
my music at your rally and it's so dumb
and it's such a Shameless Ploy for
attention
but usually they have a point usually
they can say you're playing an
unlicensed version of my song
what's amazing about Vivek shows you
that he's a graduate of the number one
Law School in the country is he
he apparently got the licenses so so
what Eminem came out and he couldn't
demand that Vivek stop rapping you know
you would think that this little rapping
type thing was just a spur of the moment
thing and maybe it was the first time
but then because Vivek is a very sharp
lawyer and a very shrewd politician even
though he's never run for anything
before
he apparently went out and got the
license so so that he could stop exactly
what Eminem is trying to do right now so
Eminem even more impotently than the
musical artists usually have to do he
comes out and he says
hey I demand that BMI who holds the
catalog I demand that BMI revoke the
license that Vivek apparently has on my
song because I don't I don't want it I
don't want it to happen
so BMI sent a letter to Vivek says this
letter serves as notice that Eminem
works are excluded from the agreement
effective immediately
BMI will consider any performance of the
m m works by the Vivek 2024 campaign
from the state forward to be a material
breach of the agreement for which BMI
reserves All rights and remedies with
respect here too so I don't legally I
don't know if they can actually do that
if they can say hold on we're taking it
out of the agreement you don't get to do
Eminem anymore
but regardless now now I have to
flip-flop because I I don't like
Eminem's alleged music and I don't like
I don't like it when serious people rap
but the vague should be wrapping at
every campaign stop now this is so funny
this is such a great way to show not
only are the conservatives bold and
courageous and willing to mix things up
and everything but that also we
sometimes can outsmart the libs too and
get those licenses okay there's a lot
there's a lot more to get to New York
City wants to
expand the public broadcast of Muslim
prayer
New York is about to become you know
Mecca or medina or something like that
uh the late night hosts have been out of
work for over three months most people
don't even know that that like Jimmy
Kimmel and those guys uh so now they're
gonna try to take my job that's what
they're going after there's so much more
to get to those that's all my teas it's
my tease for tomorrow because today is
work Wednesday we got to get to the
member block
there's a very special
display of something on the member block
that was sent in by one of you which
we'll get to in a moment
the rest of the show continues now if
you are not a member of the the Inner
Circle here of the show will join go to
dailywire.com use code Knowles at
checkout get two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]